[Music]
so i was supposed to go to for big show
yeah yeah
and i ended up writing
him and his wife an essay on why i
couldn't go so i never get out over text
this is the longest text i've ever seen
yeah it's got one of those like little
arrows yeah where like it says like push
this
yeah exactly i don't do email i fail on
email so i never get asked out on dates
ever ever ever
and this guy asked me out on a date and
i liked him i thought he was really
appealing so i was like oh my god so i
was like for biggs i've got to go do
this thing
i'm going to try and like
you know say yes to life yes exactly
so the next day i send him and his wife
a very long essay a short story if you
will
i go on the date the guy um in the first
10 minutes
basically explains how he blew up his
marriage with a torrid affair that the
daughter found out
and it's just bloody mayhem everywhere
and i'm like
i don't want any drama in my life this
is why i don't really date and then
he's like and then we have to go to this
place and we're walking and he's like
you got to lose the hat and i'm like why
he's like there's a dress code where
we're going i'm like oh my god
then he introduces me to the maitre d
and the the thing and would you like to
meet drew barrymore i was like
oh my god i hate you so much
and then they do this whole weird like
uh cannon situation and the folding of
the flag which i'm all for patriotism
but it's this smirk that this guy thinks
he's like
just doing it all so right everything i
talk about he talks about his sister
about her husband every person i bring
up i'm like
and i he does this certain occupation
and i'm like can i just talk to you
about that because that's like part of
what i think we can connect on because
it's like my passion he's like i don't
want to talk about work
and i'm like
oh my god
he drops me off in a parking lot in the
middle of like late at night in the
middle of a dark forest road
and i get out of the car and he backs up
and peels out and leaves me alone in
this dark parking lot i can't even see
the thing to get my key
and
so i wrote mike the next day and i was
like
as a text message
reading i got a text message from drew
and it's
we're gonna be reading this for a while
and then i read it to her out loud and
my takeaway of course is
this is what happens when you don't go
to a micro biglio show that's exactly
right
[Music]